bientôt aux exclusions choisir son point
de vue l'épisode de tilda on est
logiquement on devrait savoir l'identité
du foot du tueur
mais avant le précédemment de till dawn
au [ __ ] endosc ac dc je comprends pas
ce qui s'est passé parce c'est un truc
de dingue
une fois qu'on a cherché à l'aide et aux
les mecs je n'ai jamais tu me chercher
on devrait aller chercher les autres mac
et jesse son parti se tripoter et
personne ne sait où est sa voix qu'elle
est au chalet pourquoi est ce qu'on
parle encore de ça on y va et regarde
une tour de guet
[Musique]
mais c'est quoi ça changera rien
ok chapitre 6 vengeance ou cinq heures
jusqu'à l'aube à wahaha alors oui ca qu
ils étaient pourchassés par des desserts
après os cancale ou est ce qu'on
reproche elle nous sous leur propre nom
dans fed mais calme toi à quelque chose
d'avion une seconde stoxx a juste sentir
en maths négative
c'est embêtant regarde je pense faire
autour de ce mot avec ma main et tout va
bien
regarde bonjour les serres c'est quand
même bizarre ce qui se passe avec les
animaux de cette forêt 1 ça cache
quelque chose moi je vous le dis c'est
pas normal station schéma match pourri
qui m'agresse plat coup dans le crâne et
année ils me font vraiment une entrée de
roi voilà ce que je crois pas à nos
chefs dessert non mais non mais non mais
non mais ça va pas de jeu palpitant mais
il faut lui sont taries attention j'ai
remarqué le mieux souvent c'est derrière
faire en fait allez on se tire merci les
serres pour votre petite visite me fait
très plaisir et me les mois en plus elle
est insolente l énorme je n'aime pas du
tout humilié dans ce jeu c'est dingue
j'ai vraiment envie de qu'elle brûle
après j'aimerais bien que des gens
restent en vie dans ce journal il faut
leur dire qu'on a besoin d aide oui on
va y arriver on va y arriver en
attendant tétouan rentrer au chalet y
ont réuni tout le monde
c'est une excellente idée c'est parti on
y est il ya l'antenne radio mon gars oh
la vache
c'est pas normal ça non sans dec ça
c'est pas normal ça situe à venir de
sécurité à détecteur de mouvement et ça
s'allume en faisant un bruit ou aussi
flippant un décor le mouvement méfaits
soient sceptiques ou pas qui veut nous
couper la tête qu'elle met cette lampe
et qu'elle va monter cette échelle c'est
parti jambes sont qui peut nous arriver
beaucoup de malheurs à l'epide si on
arrive à contacter quelqu'un et que
cette foutue radio ok on est à l'abri
vient de fermer la trappe
on est parfaitement à l'abri au chaud
alors petit casier qu'est-ce qui est un
indice parisien lundi
voilà un indice à nawa j te ramasser les
lieux des deux soeurs qui sont voilà les
a pas retrouvés elle moi je pensais que
tu me savais qu'elle était morte
on ne les a pas retrouvées mec ok ça
change totalement le game c'est faux ça
regarde c'est quoi ces deux radios alors
pas de cours pas de courant super ya un
bouton elle a dit qu'il ya un bouton est
à mon avis le bouton il est des recettes
porte c'est sûr je regardais pas
vraiment une imprimante l'apache le
bouton et doit être vert là le sang
royal et ce petit panneau là on est trop
fort détective qu'au delà en quoi aller
à lens juste un pistolet en cas
d'urgence donnait un match aussi un peu
macho c'est un peu macho donc on va le
garder quand même là ça suffit
l'histoire du all in arms donc jadona
maintenant ah non tu la gardes tirer ou
garder ça va attirer le psychopathe mec
oui oui c'est ça attire et maintenant
c'est complètement débile à moi c'est
retrouver son bien mais qui nous aurait
vu qu'ils seraient venus nous aider
[ __ ] je regrette je sais pas on va
voir la suite si le tueur et là on
aurait dû tirer pour demander de l'aide
mais s'il n'est pas là on a bien fait
y'a pas de boutoir j'ai fait tout il ya
aucun bouton présent dans cette vidéo à
part sur mon visage adore faire cette
blague que vous avez pas me un fût ce
box parfait c'est ça on tire à l'élève
les stars va se prendre un coup de jus
dans saison parfait la radio oui on
garde espoir
on cherche on cherche une fréquence à
halo
alors à l'eau ne tombe pas non c'est ce
que j'ai dit s'il vous plaît alors pitié
de nous on est bloqué à blake ou de
montagne c'est ce que j'étais
on les a mais ils comprennent pas ce
qu'on dit c'est horrible insisté dénoue
obtempéré ok on obtempère n'obtempère on
obtempère sasahara massée à l'est [ __ ]
informée on a fort mandat fort on a fort
mal on n'assiste pas à la structure des
conscrits bassiste et là quand même
voilà personne n'a reçu le message non
il est là la faute au tir avec le gone
la frontière avec le ghana c'est [ __ ]
l'actuaire ça va pas se passer comme ça
mais ça tombe c'est lui et tueur qui a
non non non la jupe sicotte avant l'aube
comment il a dit pas avant l'autre c'est
évident au qui frappa yama tiamat matin
bonhomme est mal défoncé coups de hache
me martin matte match c'est café du thé
quoi d'autres étaient avec moi que j'en
ai fait bordage n'a jamais fait mais
testé comme avec moi bâtard je me
souviens de ta sale tronche on faisait
le poids qu ensemble sur le tata dame a
fait quoi c'est ce qui tient la tour
c'est l'un des capitiens à toi
en chine
elle est double aux riffs tout
[ __ ] c'est multiste effet pas
l'attraction réuni mon gars c'est irl
haut ils sont là et il avait de cassé
aux acquittés au hall a deux côtes
cassées et à la radio qui nous trop lent
plus emilie accroche toi
la merde
merde aux apaches mise à jour du statut
ok on est dans les mines à 2h 43 du mat
qui sont faits dans tes personne n'est
jamais allé dans des villes à 240
pendant ml je t'aime bien
c'était le mec ce que j'ai dit ah c'est
bon pour la circulation infernale arrête
le violet ce [ __ ] crétins hop est
suspicieux georges vous ai vu tous les
matchs en séries mais on peut lui
rappeler maintenant j'aurai les autres
la vie et la mort on va lui dire
'attendez jour et que nos affaires avec
match qui fut [ __ ] géant vite et j'ai
envie de faire l'enculé j'ai vraiment
envie de faire la foire et je détestais
mais du chip désolé je vous ai vu tous
les matches c'est pour ça que tu aimes
plusieurs mike c'est un intello tenace
que par les dix mois ce qui se passe
non exigeants retrouver max est finie
yves azéroual a sauvé ma troisième on a
ce jouet est finie c'est oui pour la
sauver la sombre la sombre l'assaut de
la sauve non non on n'est pas des sables
à ce point je vais pas la mort de
quelqu'un d'assez bon je veux sauver
mini je m'en fous de mam est en lieu sûr
[ __ ] j'suis pas égoïste et me dit je
te sauves [ __ ] plus a fait un truc et
persil plat les deux vont mourir non
ta voix les noms
[Musique]
vidéo
dans tous les cas je peux pas la sauver
je n'ai pas dû lui parler de ce match
j'aurais pas dû lui parler de maija je
suis le plus gros des [ __ ]
appartenait mois les la poule 1 se
retrouvent dans les mines dans le qg de
l'aude poids au met dans la merde
excusez moi je suis choquée la skieuse
s'est passé je suis choqué et là je
tombe nez à nez avec le psychopathe qui
a un fusil qui met une balle dans la
tête voilà allez pierre fin de soirée
pour cet homme
c'est un oubli on a vu son visage c'est
un zoom y regarde
what may mais hélas encore quatre
épisodes
y'a plus personne qui ont veillé tard
j'ai pris tous les choix qu'il fallait
pas quoi moi le joyau janeiro cette
terre est dure deux heures avec moi mais
c'est quoi cette créature mec c'était
pas ne s'était pas tueur ça ça c'était
chez pas un zombie des mines
un jour c'est rien mais que c'est pas la
vue depuis au moins 8 mois quoi j'en
sais rien je n'ai pas vu elle à devenir
par ici [ __ ] il reste plus qu' il
reste plus que et mike hickey dans le
l'asile voilà ni plus ni moins super
c'est quoi ça mais qu'est ce qui se
passe par ici
est-ce que je repense à la caméra qu'on
avait trouvé vous savez le trophée ou le
père de josh et des deux de hannah et
bêtes qui ont disparu et réalisateur de
films d'horreur il a gagné un prix genre
il est hyper fort est ce que tout ça là
ce n'est pas une mise en scène
actuellement je suis en train de me dire
ça est ce que josh est vraiment mort par
exemple ce que je crie pas fera
techniquement oui j'ai du mal à y croire
quoi on l'aurait vu c'était faux mais je
ne sais pas je commence à voir des
petites théorie est ce que tout ça n'est
pas juste une mise en scène sa sauce et
josh qui a mis toute cette mise en scène
pour se venger de la disparition de ses
deux soeurs on sait pas trop vite à elle
est pleine de sens c'est abusé
juste qu'à l'époque qu'elle est femme et
je crois pas sur un tueur est dangereux
la fin quoi qu ici d'ailleurs il ya un
truc que je voulais vous dire casser
attendez je déteste le sujet horreur de
ça assistez aux concédé je vais insister
mais ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
que justement le fantôme qu'elle vient
de voir
vous savez qu'on avait la table de ouija
dans l'épisode 3 je crois c'était ou
catch et plus je crois que c'est le 3 et
bars moment il y avait un plan sur eux
qu'ils étaient en train de d'invoquer
l'esprit et en fond il y avait cette
fameuse fille qui les regarde et je
l'avais pas vu et c'est vous qui me
l'avait rappelé et c'est horrible parce
que je n'avais pas vu sur le coup je me
sentis violés mesure
d'accord d'accord peut-être que tu as vu
que je n'en crois moi que roman a fait
bien trop mal non
écoute c'est le seul endroit où peut
être sam je voudrais qu'on a cherché
tous les autres sur tout mon but il ya
un bruit au monde je ne supporte pas ça
alors là tout ce qui est ce prix fantôme
as possession bla bla bla là ça pas du
tout c'est quoi ça ouais c'est une
maquette jeu sur sa ma théorie c'est une
maquette toute la scène oh c'est quand
ils l'ont filmé pour faire la blague est
cité fantôme danaé bête je crois c'est
quoi ce délire
oh c'est bon je suis sûr que c'est une
vengeance
ô ô horreur de ça j'ai horreur de ça ça
me fait penser à ce corps a touché pas
calmé oui crise va dehors mais [ __ ] le
excellent homme il va pas devant quoi
elle a pas de conduire et moi dans la
vraie vie si ça se passait quoi je
laisserai les genres ya les royals à
cliquer là j'ai la clé pour la mettre
dans la maison il a vu là il a vu là
voilà il a vu chris arrête d'être
rationnel [ __ ] alors c'est quoi cette
maison c'est quoi ces maquettes sais
c'est quoi
j'ai pas bien vu c'est quoi le délire ce
qu'on dirait non pas on dirait quand
vous attendiez ana avoila l'inversé ça
mais c'est là qu'ils ont faits précis
c'est exactement pareil pour matt je
crois qu'on a mis ça ici pour nous faire
peur mais qui josh et moi sommes
il veut nous tiens que le parent et
admet anne a et b cet [ __ ] cet
[ __ ] qui veut nous voir péter les
plombs fantôme en quoi est-ce qu'il
ferait tout ça il veut nous dire qu'il
va tous nos buts et c'est tout
[Musique]
aucun sens ce qui vient de se passer
[ __ ] c'est quoi cet endroit démarrage
un toit [ __ ] je veux faire mais lui
s'en bat les couilles
non mais non mais il est coopté achevé
je disais j'aime j'aime pas je vais me
couper un [ __ ] de doigts tout comme
mike l'a fait voilà toujours à bras
d'homme viril et tout comme lui comme
croyez pas y aller on trouve des petits
crânes de plus le groupe est là avec à
l'achat [ __ ] j'me casse
c'est quoi un colis ça adresse de retour
qualité d'un allemand die welt a ses
défauts pourquoi quelqu'un imprimerie de
faux journaux en question ou la houlala
il se passe quoi là défaut journaux mon
gars c'est moi je suis plus tard mais
alors la là j'ai envie tant à ce qui se
passe bordel là je suis complètement
largué je commence à voir un mauvais
pressentiment art est négative c'est
juste que je peux pas m'empêcher de
penser que c'est faux journaux sont
liées au tibia twitch attends attends
attends
comme quoi alors une sorte de mise en
scène ouais mais comment on fait
batterie minuterie pour la télé et pour
la lumière watts
non mais voilà tout est un coup monté
voilà c'est vraiment l' indice du de
sark leur père est un grand réalisateur
de films d'horreur qui m'a mis sur cette
voie là après peut-être que je me trompe
encore une fois mais là je le sens bien
là là je me semble regarder des
mannequins des trucks et utilisant des
films tout ça là
sassou je me trompe oh non je vais être
du côté là j'aurais pu et de l'autre
côté
merde y'a des photos là c'est les photos
de nous c'est ça de ses cibles
voilà mais y'a josh via l aquila fait
une des croix sur les yeux c'est qui
c'est emilie je crois bombes à eau c'est
quoi ça ce que j'ai vu ce thème juste de
la base de cette famille faut qu'on
aille voir là ok alors on doit vraiment
se magner maintenant enquêter mouvement
insufflé je suis crise ne jamais se
séparer mon gars je suis crise ça j'en
ai marre j'ai vu trop de gens mourir là
à gauche
elle est morte mais bon un truc salle
non c'est bon [ __ ] mais elle n'est pas
morte à 28 16 ans espère encore c'est
vrai [ __ ] qu'est ce que la semaad oui
au nom devant la porte et ça me pénalise
de faire toi
[Musique]
m
super mais tous en rang d'oddo qui est
ce métier ce mec est ce mec [ __ ] des
caméras on fait comment
c'est quoi le but là c'est sow il ya
dossier aux tumeurs non mais je vais
défoncer sa [ __ ] de gueule ouais mais
fais pas le malin toi je suis sûr que
c'est josh le m
[Musique]
il ya un piste le meilleur
[Applaudissements]
non non non ce que j'apprenne une
question importante
et là il comprendre notre habitat avait
laissé le jeu peut prendre le pistolet
devant toi et tu achètes pour tous tués
à fait celui qui reste très stable
soit le parti ne veut pas les dieux
futur carnet de bord je vais tuer aucun
des deux soit je me buts soit je bute à
chaque fois moi le choix choisir cette
fois les squats sommeil une chose à
faire dans ma vie l'ès wasquehal
m
je vais rien faire je vais rien faire je
vais rien faire buck j'te devait être le
tueur je vais je fais rien je fais rien
bebel nous stresser pour qu'on agisse
dans la panique je vais rien faire
décidons s'arrêter à ça nos crânes c'est
tout
c'est du mensonge c'est dur pour les a
pas vus mourir
watchmen qui tremblaient par deux ans je
le disais je comprenais pas ce qui se
passait c'est du mensonge en a aucun qui
est mort [ __ ] c'est le psy oui c'est
toujours pas qui est le tueur ne
comprenez vous pas que cette torture a
duré assez longtemps
ok parfait vous êtes cinglés vous êtes
un [ __ ] de taré mais qu'est ce que
vous leur avez fait c'est quoi le délire
qu'est ce que vous leur avez fait quoi
délire psychopathe
ok oui mais les gens c'est de la fin de
cet épisode sur un tilda alors là je
crois qu'on atteint l'apogée de tout ce
qui pouvait se passer de pierre de
plaintes record de plus [ __ ] de merde
je suis choqué c'est à dire que la
loppsi ne s'adresse plus à nous mais on
voit s'adresser aux psychopathes donc
est-ce qu'on était le psychopathe en
fait et ce qu'est ce qu'on présente une
psychopathe qui consulte un psy ou genre
dans sa tête il a une petite voix qui
lui dit cependant ce que tu fais mais il
le fait quand même pas je l'aï nous
manque des éléments méchant que très
bientôt
on peut flairer le truc monde auquel
j'adhère ont trouvé pour l'épisode
suivant que je vais tourner tout de
suite à belle vidéo basse d'avoir
regardé j'espère que ça les côtés de
vous plaire à bientôt
j'ai tout le monde pis
[Rires]